so rich meaty colorful oh the weave it's
so pretty
look at that weave hey I'm Matthew
Francis a tasty chef and producer and
here is my family's recipe for Pizza
Rustica you start off with making the
dough Pizza Rustica is a savory pizza
pie filled with eggs Italian cheeses and
cured meats the way I know it is from my
great-grandma Lulu who's like the
matriarch of my family she's a beast she
is a force of nature and I think she
gets that from her mother and from her
grandmother these little strong Italian
women who just did not take any and I
think they'd be proud to see this if
they didn't pratik me and how I made it
when I was a little kid I didn't know
other people made Pizza Rustica we call
it Easter Pete's I don't know it's
because my family's just lame and we
shortened it because we're lazy but it's
funny look how smooth that is it's a
perfect texture love me some meat man
you get some sweetness from the ham
spice from the pepperoni saltiness from
the salami a little bit of spunk from
the prosciutto everything balances out
together see that texture it's not too
wet not too dry look how much this dough
ropes and loop now for my favorite part
I love kneading pizza dough I know many
families decide to make a sweet or
savory pie crust for this dish but my
mother's side has passed down this pizza
dough recipe to make I think the best
pizzas together is out there don't get
bogged down with the specifics it's okay
if your family's recipe is different
than mine and that's the beauty of food
take what you love from that dish and
make it your own
my family will always make Pizza Rustica
on either Good Friday or Holy Saturday
and you have to wait until Easter Sunday
to eat it because in the olden days of
Italy meat was a luxury or people would
be fasting during Lent and my grandma
had to wait until a special occasion
like Easter to have Pizza Rustica which
means now we all have to wait
I know it's unhealthy but guess what
that's why you have it just once a year
because it's so freakin good enjoy it
try your best to get a good look
I'm not perfect my mom's way better at
than I am then grab some egg wash and
give it a little bit of our brushy-brush
and into the oven she goes every kid in
the family had like a separate job to do
and grandma Lulu she'll like have her
arms crossed and so like walk across the
kitchen and like look over and be like
more parsley oh my god
that could not look better I left my
hometown to go to culinary school when I
was 18 so for the last 4 years I
actually haven't been able to make this
during Easter when I cook family recipes
it makes me feel like they're in the
kitchen with me try Pizza Rustica you're
going to appreciate your loved ones so
much more this is why I love cooking so
much because it's about telling a story
through food
nailed it great I'm gonna take this to
go thank you very much oh yes
[Music]